let's bring you some other news also
dropping in just now the Palestinian red
cresant says they have received a
warning from the Israeli military forces
to immediately evacuate gaza's alud
Hospital let's go to yumna state she
joins us now on the phone from Gaza City
so yumna first of all this do we know is
this Hospital a functioning Hospital
full of
people well yes
now not all Departments of the hospital
are working because um the lack of
electricity but the hospital certainly
has over 12,000 people Sheltering in the
hospital of uh of Al Hospital especially
those people who have had their uh homes
targeted in t Hawa neighborhood now we
know that in t Hawa neighborhood they
were the residential uh towers of Hawa
that were completely uh bombarded and
leveled to the ground thousands of
families had to evacuate in addition to
other areas in that neighborhood that
are all Sheltering in that hospital now
I got a call from Dr Bashar Murad who is
the director of Al hospital and he uh
told me exactly that he got a call from
the Israeli Army telling him to
instantly EV Evacuate the hospital and
everyone in it to the southern strip
that's toan unit and he said that this
is because the Army is about to conduct
a military operation in that area now Dr
are they evacuating I mean it's quite a
distance from Gaza City to Khan unun can
they evacuate what about people who are
in bad condition in the hospital who
might not be
mobile that is exactly what Dr Murad
told me he told me I replied to that uh
Personnel from the Israeli Army I said
if you want us to evacuate please
provide us with the necessary buses and
transportation means so that we can
evacuate over 12,000 people and patient
into the South and make a place for us
he told me that the uh person speaking
to him from the Israeli Army on the
other uh line uh started shouting and
screaming and he told him you can bear
the consequences if you do not evacuate
and then hang
up so yumna are you telling us and
viewers that we are
potentially waiting and watching a
hospital full of people that cannot
evacuate that might be on the verge of
the receiving end of an Israeli air
strike that is what we are actually
reporting now and we are reporting this
step by step so that if this Hospital
gets targeted in the upcoming hours or
even the coming days we know that this
hospital was warned clearly to evacuate
or otherwise there the
consequences of what is going to happen
this warning yumna came to the
Federation of the red cresant is that
right and it makes me wonder is there
any room for the International
Federation of the Red Cross and the red
Cresent on an international scale do we
know if there's any contacts going on to
try and get the Israelis to resend
this I was told by Dr Murad when he was
delivering this information to me
instantly that he is going to instantly
contact the Red Cross and see what to do
about this wording and this threat so
yes there is of course a connection
between the red Cresent and the Red
Cross they're both International
organizations that uh are operating
under international law in many
countries sty so if is any kind of
connection now made to the Red Cross
going to be uh able to to uh change uh
the decision of the Israeli Army from
targeting or uh conducting a military
operation as they say in that area and
targeting Al hospital that is what we
are about to or we are waiting to see
also Mur told me that he will be
conducting an urgent uh press conference
in the time being in the upcoming uh
half an hour or hour or so to let the
entire world know about this warning and
this threat so that the entire world can
know what is really
happening you I'm going to ask you to
stay with us because as our viewers will
see on the left side of the screen we
just saw some
explosion explosions there light up the
horizons over guard of course one hopes
one hopes those are not Israeli air
strikes falling on the alud hospital do
you have any idea of what those
explosions are and whether or not that
was indeed the
hospital well Shi let me tell you it's
not just the AL Hospital in neighborhood
that has been warned to evacuate now you
know that I live in t neighborhood as
well and the street just before our
street where the Red Cross itself the
headquarters of the Red Cross in Gaza
City schs that entire Street was warned
today to
evacuate so we did go to the Red Cross
building and we asked them because
building is very much closer to that
street and they told us that they
already uated the a
days
ago right so the bombardments that have
been ongoing for the past two days in in
different areas of they seem to be
spreading more and more now targeting
other areas in that same
neighborhood yumna I think you said
there was a thousand people correct me
if I'm wrong in this hospital I'm just
thinking th000 people
12,000 yes 12,000 people just give us an
idea of the kind of
logistics which might or might not be
available to move 12,000 people from
Gaza City a hospital in Gaza City all
the way down to Khan
yunice there is there are no
Transportation means for for this huge
to be evacuated or transported to
another area you need uh uh you need
Transportation so there are no buses
there are no cars there's no fuel in the
strp already the strp has been in lack
of fuel and has been in difficulties and
crisis of finding fuel all these past
days so it's it's a it's a huge PR for
people now to move from place to another
we're talking about moving from Gaza
City to the south at least an hour drive
so where will people get that amount of
amount of buses the numbers the amount
of fuel enough for them to be
transported all that uh all that
distance and over all that or on top of
all that where are they going to stay
because we know that every owna shelter
in the South fully occupied I'm talking
about schools I'm talking about centers
I'm talking about clinics and I'm
talking about even governmental
hospitals like n hospital and Nar
hospital and the European Hospital the
three larg hospitals in the South both
in Han unit in Raa so where will that
number of people be able to be
evacuated that's why when Dr Murad said
he told him this is an
impossible request that you are making
and you know that it's an impossible
request and nothing can be about
it all right yumna say there we're going
to give you a chance to catch up on on
what's Happening thank you y for
updating us so far and just to bring
viewers up to speed with these very
dramatic moment moments which we are we
are living through and witnessing right
now the situation is we understand that
Al's Hospital in Gaza City has been told
to evacuate
immediately the director of that
hospital telling Israeli military
authorities who gave him that order that
it's impossible they have 12,000 people
there and we've seen at the same time on
the left hand of the screen you'll see
we saw moments ago what appeared to be
some flashes in the sky we don't know
of course exactly what this what that is
but one hopes one fears one certainly
hopes that is not the result of Israeli
air strikes on the hospital we we don't
know that but there is a lot of concern
obviously in these dramatic moments to
know what will be the fate of those
12,000 people some of them patience some
of them as yumna said people who are HED
up in the hospital because they've come
from their homes which were destroyed